why are people talking about Governor  Romney as a potential nominee what is  that what is driving that I think  there's some buyer's remorse  I think people now know what what kind  of person MIT is I think that thing a  Netflix that meant that's the mitten we  knew and that didn't come out as well in  a presidential campaign and also I think  people realize that a lot of the things  he said in the campaign the projections  he made with respect to Russia and Iraq  and others were true and so I think  people commit mania in America there's a  bit me and I'm unbalanced sign me up for  the MIT mania if he runs would you  support it absolutely I Drive his bus if  you ask me